hello
i am tiranis kenyan from calculus and
algebra group
at wolfram so today i will talk about
mathematical functions new developments
and and function properties
so here is the abstract that was
available in the pathable
uh and i will directly turn to the
overview of the talk
so first i'm going to talk about
new features in mathematical functions
then i will turn to wholenomic functions
talk about what we have done for 12.2
upcoming
and at the end i will finish my
presentation with
some examples of analysis function
analysis
with a new functionality that will be in
12.2
okay so here is a
slide with recent progress
uh in the area of mathematical functions
so we are of course constantly improving
all the available functionality as well
as developing and implementing some new
mathematical functions uh
just a couple of notes so we have
updated uh
significantly documentation pages the
basic examples section and scope
example section in 12.0 and 12.1
and you can just go to the
mathematical functions guide or special
functions guide and
check different new examples
in the documentation pages also
starting from we 11.3 developing
a very powerful asymptotic functionality
um also we have implemented five new
coin functions with their derivatives uh
in version 12.1 and for 12.2
we have improved dissolve now it's
solving
a lot of new examples uh added
implemented two new elliptic functions
and also
implemented the family of llama
functions
that are special functions
so i will here give a just brief
overview
on mathematical functions and on the
philosophy that we are
using so key idea here is that most of
the mathematical functions
uh elementary functions special
functions are solutions of
uh ordinary differential equations and
in fact these differential equations can
be
used as data structures so if we will if
we are working with the differential
equations then we have a lot of
additional information
that we can use for example we all know
that
the exponential function is solving this
simple differential equation
the bessel functions that are very
popular and famous
are solving a more difficult equation
with singular points
and probably the most famous function
special function mathematical function
is the hyper geometric to f1 function
and that is solving a differential
equation with
three regular singular points so
hypergeometric functions uh generalize
all the simpler mathematical functions
and in fact hypergeometric functions
played a crucial role
in the development of science during the
20th century
but of course there are more advanced
more complex
special functions so the spheroidal
functions are
examples they are solving this equation
in 12.1 we made a big step in this field
implemented the family of coin functions
uh that the main function of this family
is general hang function
and there are also four confluent forms
of it so the general point function is
solving this equation
and the important point is that hone
functions directly generalize
all the hyper geometric class of
functions all the functions from
microgeometric class
like uh home g that is the general honey
function
generalized the hyper geometric to f1
function and join c that is the single
confluent point function generalizes
the hypergeometric one f1 function
however
if you will check the list of special
functions
there is there there there was a family
of
special functions that was missing
involved from language
and this was the family of a functions
and as we don't have it them in wolfram
language then we weren't able to solve
the llama equation
till the version 12.2 so
the llama equation is this equation and
in the upcoming version of wolf from
language we will be able to solve it
so if you are in general interested uh
in this topic then you can just check my
blog post that is i think that that is
well written and rather detailed however
as we don't have a lot of time i will
i will skip this and directly go to
in to the new features in 12.2
so as i've mentioned we've implemented
la
functions
these are two there are two long
functions lama c and lames functions
uh also they're primes and
two eigenvalue functions because uh in
fact
in the literature the lame equation
we are solving uh again the egg value
problem
so this is a new step in the theory of
special functions
because la may functions are implemented
only involved from language so this will
be something new
material functions are their limited
limit cases
in fact lumi functions are members of
home functions family that we have
recently implemented
but their importance is that
lamar equation and lamar functions
solve different problems a big set of
problems from mathematical physics and
quantum mechanics
and because of this we have implemented
this function so i think that
these functions will be rather useful
and also
implementing them in 12.2 we will
activate
the research in this in this area as
we have already seen that when we have
implemented home functions in 12.1
researchers started using using them and
in general the field is activated
as we don't have a lot of time i will
just give another general overview
so uh lama equation is the following
equation
two lame functions are implemented lama
c and lama s
so this equation
is solved in terms of lambda c or lamb s
only if this parameter h is specified to
lame eigen value a
or lamb again value b and here is the
example of solving this equation
uh here are some plots of these
functions ah yeah
interestingly these laminar functions
include sine and cosine functions as
special cases
when the elliptic parameter in lambda
functions the last parameter is zero
and this is uh very easy to understand
because the lama equation is written
here
and if this parameter is 0 then this is
just a
equation for sine and cosine functions
now i will give some plots of my
functions so this is a plot
the 3d plot of my c
here will be the plot of lama s for
different values of
elliptic parameter
uh these functions are doubly periodic
i will plot them and this
periodicity the period is depends on the
order
j the second parameter of lambda
functions
uh some words about the eigenvalues
and derivatives so we were forced to
implement the derivatives
lambda c prime and lamb s prime because
the
derivatives of lambda functions are not
functions of the same class
and because of this we've implemented
them and
their usage is in fact only while
calculating the derivatives of linear
functions
so here is the third derivative of lama
s and here we see lamar spray
about the eigenvalues not a lot to say
here is the plot and here i am showing
that
this equilame equation is solved only
this parameter
is specified to lame in value a
an interes interesting feature of lamar
functions is that
there is a connection between laminar
functions and omg functions
in fact lamia functions are proportional
to omg functions
with specified parameters
and this is because the lama equation is
algebraic form
here it is is nothing more than a
general joint equation
and we see that if this h is arbitrary
then the equation is solved in one g
functions
now let's turn to the next uh two new
functions two
new elliptic functions so
uh one function is called uh jacobi
epsilon
it's an important elliptic integral
related to jacobi dn so here is the
definition
and the one of the so it can be used to
calculate derivatives of the equivalent
functions
with respect to an elective parameter
here it is
other applications might be found in the
application parts
of documentation page of this function
the second function is jakob zn so here
is the definition and we see that it's
uh real closely related to jacobi
epsilon function
and here is a very presentable example
how we can use this function
so uh this is a zero energy solution
for the following periodic potential for
for the supersymmetric analog of this
periodic potential
and by direct
subsubstitution we can verify this
so here it is for extended discussion
of this topic of jacobi elliptic
functions integrals and so on
check the guide page because it's it
contains a lot of interesting examples
okay next next
improvement is connected with the
holdomic functions
so the key idea here is that
you we are giving a possibility to user
to define its own special function or
sequence giving
just the differential equation initial
values or the difference equation and
initial values so if the user is
interested in some function
that is not implemented involved from
language and then a
user can define its own function and
work with it
uh also take a look on this nice new
type setting
that is also implemented for and
prepared for 12.2 so here is the
here is the old type setting and here is
the new type setting
it's nice and i really like it
so else we have implemented we have
significantly improved the documentation
pages
for the differential root and difference
root functions
we have implemented a new method of
differential root calculations
and here we are using a series based
analytic continuation procedure
now we have a better performance and a
lot of uh interesting features like
parametric derivatives of difference
root
and also a new type setting that i've
already mentioned
uh here i will give just a brief
functionality how we can work with this
differential root and difference root
functions
so for example if you are solving some
equation
that is unsolved in non-mathematical
functions then the output will be
differential root object
but however you can use it just any
other
mathematical function involved from
language for example you can calculate
some
some values you can plot this solution
you can calculate derivative of it you
can make some asymptotic analysis
this is very cool also you can use a
function called differential root reduce
to
for example generate the differential
equation that is
obeyed by bessel functions for example
here you can use
here you can use combination of
different functions
in any case you will receive the
differential equation and the initial
and corresponding initial values
uh about difference root so you can
define your own sequence
calculate some say 10th term of it you
can generate a function
which taylor expansion is this above
given
difference difference with object and
of course you can verify the result
calculating back the s and the series
nth coefficient this is precalculated
because it will take some time
also you can use difference root radius
now to
calculate for example the difference
equation that is obeyed by vessel
functions
vessel sequence uh interesting point is
that you can also
have some parametric sequences work with
them absolutely right
right like in the same way like another
uh mathematical function or sequence
okay uh so this was about holonomic
functions
uh and now i will turn to the last
part of my presentation that is on
function properties
uh so this is an import important
improvement
for the analysis of function properties
it will be available in 12.2
there are three general sets of
functions that are
analyzing the theoretical properties of
functions some analytic properties
and functions like this so i think that
everything is
more or less understandable here and
i will show some examples how
i'm using this functionality for a nulls
okay so here i took the very simple
cosine function
and i am very interested if this
function is continuous is
injective subjective or bijective
so here will be the output and of course
plotting this function we can verify the
result
uh also using these function properties
you can
get the for get the conditions when the
function is continuous monotonic and
and and something like this so for
example let's take
a rather complex function like this
difficult function like this and
generate the conditions when it's
continuous so
it's continuous when these conditions
are satisfied
another example let's take a function
like this
and get the monotony and get the
conditions when it's monotonic so here
it is
of course you can use the function
analytic
function to
check if this function is analytic this
one is analytic this one is not
and of course you can use the plot3d
to verify the result so here we truly
see that the first function is
analytic the second one isn't analytic
uh of course you can work on a complex
domain
for example here i'm checking if this
function is continuous on the complex
domain
and they're also using the
powerful complex called 3d function
to to verify the result so we truly see
that
it's not continuous and here is the plot
of it
so we see that there are two singular
points
and you can get you can use this
functionality to
generate the set of singular points for
example i took the
gamma function and then generating the
singular points list
list so here it is you can of course use
this functionality to
get the discontinuities for example i
took the bezel function for some
parameter and here is the discontinuity
and then of course i can verify the
result using complex plot 3d function
so here it is and this is the origin
and we see that there is the
discontinuity
going to minus infinity on real axis
and the last example for today is
the case of hypergeometric function so
i'm just
taking hypergeometric to f1 function
plotting it we know that there is a
singular singularity at one
and just checking that function
singularities is giving the correct
output
and of course i can also generate more
more general conditions on a complex
domain so here it is
i will repeat that this is an in in my
opinion this is a very important
improvement
and will be very useful for both
students researchers and
other individuals from the industry
so in fact this is all for today and i
want to thank you
for your attention and i'm ready to
answer
some questions if they're
okay hello
[Music]
hello can you hear me yes yes i can hear
you
yeah hello my name is i would like to
ask um
actually a couple of questions to you
okay
uh so first of all all uh uh
so um equations that you mentioned
at the very beginning uh the whole
equation hypothetical equation
and so on as a derivative of the whole
equation are examples of
in general of function equations with
certain uh singular points well i mean
um
and of course and they're confident
cases did you plan to
implement just to the general linear
equation and
try to classify it or something like
this
uh in fact the holonomic uh differential
root is doing it
but do you take into account all special
values of the parameters as it might
happen
for instance at some uh at some special
values of the parameters the apparent
singularity might
appear and for instance the whole
equation the derivative of the whole
equation
with the linear equation might reduce to
the point equation itself
if you see what i mean uh for the horn
case
this this is done manually i think but
uh
i i don't think that will do it for the
general case
did you implement any kind of
quadratic and in general uh say cubic
transformations
between say higher geometric functions
or between coin and hypergeometric
functions
again which happens to the parameters
yes there are some examples that i have
implemented
not all the examples that can be found
in the literature but
uh most important ones are implemented
for sure
yeah and uh what about um so you spoke
about
some asymptotic expansions uh uh did you
implement also expansions containing
sale logs rocks
yeah logarithmic functions and no no
yeah the the problem with hoing
functions is that they are very general
and the theory for them is
not complete so because of this there
are there are different articles
but most of the articles are tackling
some specific problems not general
problems
and because of this there is some trait
of what to implement and what
not to implement i see and uh the last
question
um so you spoke about in general
about singularities but times
say if we are looking at the linear
equations
some singularities might be apparent yes
yes
you classify somehow well i mean do you
eliminate
such kind of cases or or this is you you
take some again generic values of the
parameters
uh no we are taking all the general
general values
okay thank you thank you for your
questions
uh i see that olek is here
and
hello lake i have unmuted you yeah
okay uh how about function branch cut
i don't see this characteristic in a
list of new characteristics
discontinuities or branch cuts no
uh logarithm from that branch cut from
minus infinity to
zero uh to show a line
where we have branch cuts
for which functions for arcsign for
example for
varying for compositions of this
yeah i think that you can you can go to
the documentation page and
take examples from the function site has
this characteristic yeah also and also
the function site of course
yeah why not implement it yet
forgotten though
so i think that adam can can answer this
question and
also it's nice to have
a special plotting for branch cut
to show where we have branch cards for
each function
uh before my talk there was a talk on
complex visualization and they were
showing
very different and very powerful
plotting techniques so more or less this
is done i think
not for the old functions of course but
for for the elementary ones everything
is done i think
okay
okay so are there some other questions
well i've checked this pathable right it
seems that there are no
additional questions nice talk uh yeah
thank you devendra
uh thank you john uh
then if there are no questions i think
that we can stop here
um we may have some one more question
yes of course uh do you plan to go into
some non-linear special functions
yes it will be done one feature
what particular do you plan to implement
uh the next chapter in the digital
library of mathematical functions
so which one is that apparently the
function functions
so what what particular functionality do
you plan to implement
them i don't i i cannot say
because this is a very very future thing
but of course there are plans to
implement
also non-linear sum equations functions
okay thank you
okay uh ah there is a question
uh yes i think that fox
age so the question is about uh will the
fox h function
be implementing are we working on this
yes probably it will be we will start
actively working on this after this
release upcoming release and thank you
for a question
okay i will wait maybe one more minute
for some questions maybe
and how do you plan to work with movable
singularities and nonlinear equations
uh i cannot answer this question at the
moment thank you
but i know that you are actively working
on the topic so
probably i will ask some questions
yeah so thank you
so can i say something yes of course
okay fox should come uh with
its important uh cases uh we have
only one case uh meter clever
but other cases like write functions
should be their their analogous of
hyper geometric pfq function
and uh of course uh
interesting question uh
you converted this
differential routes into series
and in many situations such series
can be recognized as expansions of
already existing functions right right
functions
right and you will be able to
restore and convert this root
differential into basil and other
known functions for us you can go
also through mere g in this procedure
are you doing this or plan to do
i think that we'll start working on this
okay i think that
time is more or less over so once more
thank you everyone
for your time and uh
goodbye goodbye very interesting talk
yes yes thank you goodbye